this is [__] the USA this New York
City you don't have a [__] right to
touch that [__] this is a free country
you can away your Palestine flag and say
death to the Jews or America whatever
you want but we can put a [__] sign
that video contained a lot of f bombs
and frankly he's right the First
Amendment grants Americans free speech
and that includes hateful hurtful or
repulsive speech you might not like but
the Israel Palestine protests have shown
just how much people hate Free Speech
when it's speech they disagree with
across the country people are tearing
down Flyers of missing or kidnapped
Israelis on college campuses students
are stealing flags from pro-israel
supporters and protesters are trying to
prevent journalists from even reporting
at Pro Palestine events on the flip side
Republicans like Ronda santis and Tim
Scott are trying to deport students on
temporary visas for protesting Israel
let me be clear some of the signs and
statements coming out of these protests
are absolutely vile but people shouldn't
have their free speech stifled because
of it